we have another big reason to be proud
today for more girls love satellites
were successfully launched from the
European spaceport in French Guiana on
the European launcher Ariane 5 this
brings us to a constellation of 26
satellites and one step closer to
Galileo's full operational capability in
2020 and did you know that these
guerrilla lights are named after four
children Hannah from Finland
Sam well from Slovakia Tara from
Slovenia and Elaine from Sweden the
drawings won our competition and now
they're part of history space really
matters what happens up there has a big
impact on our lives down here in many
areas we depend on the technology data
and services that space helps deliver
just imagine rescue searches Smart Watch
is farming or play navigation
in fact Galileo provides positioning and
timing services to around 400 million
users European consumers should know
that a mobile device is probably Galileo
compliant soon even Galileo dependent
drivers should know that the cars are
equipped with the Galileo enabled rescue
system Eco actually with the record
precision of 20 centimeters that we
expect in 2020 Gallo
will be the most precise satellite
navigation system in the world this will
have a huge impact on connected and
autonomous driving which can amount to
yet another tectonic shift not only in
transport but in our societies at large
so as you can see space is not the final
frontier as we used to hear on Star Trek
space is becoming a new economic
frontier as it is driving a profound
modernization of our economies we
therefore need to strive for Europe's
global leadership and strategic autonomy